Joe Biden lays out his quest to save the
soul of the nation other Democrats tear
into Trump voters in Michael Moore won't
be riding an exercise bike anytime soon
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show that michael moore line right there
that actually is not really a joke he
actually says he's not gonna ride an
exercise bike anymore to which the
question becomes what was that ever a
thing don't you have to ride it once to
not ride it again but in any case we'll
get to the news in just one second first
let's talk about how you need a suit
that actually does fit you you can go to
the department store you can pick up a
suit and the truth is it'll probably
hang off you like a curtain instead what
you need is a suit that is made to
measure for you a suit that is made to
order for you just like James Bond you
want a suit that makes you look awesome
and this is where Indo Chino comes in I
notice I have an Indo Chino suit they
make suits and shirts to your exact
measurements your Indo Chino suit it's
made for you may have a tension to
detail it beat any department store if
you're in the middle of planning a
wedding actually this is really good
they have a lot of options for people
looking to outfit their wedding party so
here's how it works
you can visit one of their showrooms
Indo Chino has over 40 showrooms in
North America a stylist will then take
our measurements personally I've done
this before I went down to Santa Monica
and said this is really terrific it does
make you feel like you're on Savile Row
and in London or something it's really
awesome you can measure it at home
otherwise and shop online in Indo Chino
calm you can choose all the
personalizations the fabric inside and
out lapel lining buttons you can even
write your own monogram in touch you
know professionally tailors your suit
and then mails it to you in just a
couple of weeks this week my listeners
can get any improve endo Chino suit for
just 369 bucks at endo Chino calm when
you enter Shapiro at checkout that is
50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free Indo Chino kaam promo
code Shapiro for any premium suit 369
and free shipping
incredible deal premium made-to-measure
suit doesn't get better than that gonna
be much better than anything you get off
the rack once you go custom you don't go
back go check them out Indo Chino kaam
promo code Shapiro ok so right now the
question as to whether President Trump
is reelected is largely not about Trump
Trump is just what Trump is and as we'll
see that ain't changing for both good
and ill and when it comes to winning the
suburban women when it comes to winning
the swing states the polls show that
president Trump's personality contrary
to the popular opinion on the right his
personality is not going to help him win
the election his personality is a real
detriment to him in the 2020 election
there's a new poll out from new hit from
from Pennsylvania this is a state that
he actually needs to win and contrary to
popular opinion he is just getting blown
up in Pennsylvania
his Pennsylvania poll numbers are awful
the current Pennsylvania poll numbers
have him underwater by nearly 20 points
in terms of favorable and unfavorable
Trump 39 favorable 58 percent
unfavorable 52% strong unfavorable only
38% of people in Pennsylvania say that
Trump deserves re-election
61% say that it's time for a change now
maybe that changes once the Democrats
pick their person and this is what Trump
is hoping and so this is why I say the
2020 election is not going to be really
about whether Trump can change his
stripes because he ain't changing and I
think that everybody knows this at this
point we can be very hopeful about his
character and how he chooses to feature
it in the campaign and then we can be
realistic which is that he's going to
tweet out dumb stuff he's going to say
things that offend a lot of people he's
going to hit some of the right targets
and the right will cheer but he's not
gonna win over anybody new unless he is
able to downplay the aspects of his
personality that so many people find
off-putting and right now that's a
problem for him it's a serious problem
for him as we'll see so the Democrats
then are left with a choice and the
choices are we going to be fully crazy
we're gonna let Trump Travis Nutt are we
going to castigate anybody who ever
voted for Trump as evil and terrible are
we gonna cast gate current 8 from voters
people who are thinking about voting for
Trump in 2020 are we going to castigate
those people as racists and white
supremacist who don't care about racism
as people who don't care about shootings
and I'll pass on wal-mart's or are we
going to restrict our fire just to the
candidate on the other side and this is
largely the divide between Joe Biden and
the rest of the left it's why Joe Biden
in all of the national polls does pretty
well against President Trump and it's
why Trump is basically running even with
every other Democrat because Biden
apparently is the only Democrat in the
race who seems to have any sort of
understanding you can't just alienate
half of the American population by
calling them white supremacist and then
hope to win the presidency you can't
just call everybody a deplorable and
then hope to win now so I think the
Biden will be able to maintain that
stance I have my doubts I think that he
might
right back into what the rest of the
Democrats have been saying but Trump's
greatest hope lies in the Democrats
showing their true stripes showing their
true stripes his best hope lies in the
Democrats revealing that what they
actually believe is the same sort of
stuff as the radical left and that
really the two are tied at the hip
that's why Trump has worked so hard to
try and make the squad the face of the
Democratic Party as opposed to for
example Joe Biden it's why every time
the Democrats decide to go crazy into a
crazy thing Trump features it because
the more radical Democrats appear the
more people may be willing to overlook
Trump's personal foibles and personality
quirks to say the least and character
flaws and vote for him just because the
Democrats are so alienating so we bring
you the most alienating Democratic
talking point of the day so this started
a couple of days ago when Joaquin Castro
decided that it would be a wonderful
idea to simply post the names and
addresses not not address me but the
names and workplaces and and careers of
people in his district too it donated to
President Trump and then he said it
wasn't meant to intimidate it wasn't
meant to intimidate all of these people
it was just meant to shame them really
okay obviously it was meant as an
intimidation tactic it was really ugly
it was really disgusting and in today's
political environment it was
unjustifiable on any level which is why
Joaquin Castro couldn't justify it he
appeared on MSNBC and he had no good
comeback - dude you're actually putting
people in danger you're putting people's
faces in front of other people who want
to hurt them for supporting the current
President of the United States as it
turns out Joaquin Castro was also an
idiot six of the Trump donors that
Joaquin Castro tried to shame also gave
money to him and his brother Julian
according to the Washington Examiner
according to the examiner and attempting
to embarrass constituents who donated to
president Trump Texas congressman
Joaquin Castro appears to have
overlooked the fact that six of those he
named also gave cash to him and his twin
brother 20/20 Democrat who lien Castro
shocker so this all started a couple
days ago right only in Castro did this
and then Joe Scarborough came out and
said this is a great idea
we need to shame everyone who ever gave
to Trump if he gave to Trump at any
point in the recent past that any time
then this means that you are a white
supremacist
who doesn't care if people get shot in
El Paso Walmart for being Latino hey
this is the pitch and many members of
the media started parroting this well
there's nothing wrong with all this Nick
confess Ori a reporter at The New York
Times started actually tweeting out
yesterday the the associations between
companies and their shareholders why
because yesterday there was a big blow
up a big blowup about exercise bikes now
you ask yourself what the hell does
exercise bikes have anything to do with
anything well good thing you asked I
will tell you according to Fox News
Steven Ross owner of the NFL's Miami
Dolphins fired back Wednesday at critics
of President Trump defending his plans
to host a fundraiser for Trump on Friday
at his Hamptons home on New York's Long
Island Trump himself is expected to
attend the event at which donors can
have their photo taken with the
president for 100 grand or attend a
private roundtable discussion with him
for two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars ok so what's the problem he's
just a trump donor right well it turns
out that he is also the chief investor
in equinox and solstice brands that are
sort of upper ends and very trendy among
I'd say the coastal set it's funny
there's sort of a hierarchy in Los
Angeles in terms of the gyms that are
out here and everybody knows that the
gyms are not really ordered by the
niceness of their facility but by the
attractiveness of their people meaning
Equinox in Seoul so
people who go to Equinox and soul so are
the people who bike every day they do
spin classes they're the people who are
the most attractive a lot of Hollywood
stars whose Equinox and soul so
very socially conscious company meaning
an SJW company that likes to virtue
signal about LGBT issues for example
very very social justice oriented
left-leaning company in terms of its
corporate practices equinox and solo and
then if you go all the way down on the
scale like Gold's Gym out here they say
that's for people who are sort of
meatheads who lift a lot and sometimes
do steroids and then you've got like the
YMCA which is for the people who really
don't have any other place to work out
and they got like the 24 hour fitness
which is like everybody kind of a broad
spectrum but mainly people who barely
have time after work and buy a fitness
regimen and then don't actually go and
show up so equinox and solstice at the
top of the food chain for gyms in Los
Angeles now the left has now called for
a boycott of Equinox and soul soul so
they're not going to go to their spin
classes to beat the
to harm the cons or something so we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna hurt the
cons by not going to SoulCycle find
uncle your spin class see if I care why
would I possibly care whether you go to
your spin class and by the way if you
actually think that Steven Ross who owns
the Miami Dolphins and is worth probably
a billion dollars or more that he deeply
cares whether you go to his spin class
that he doesn't associate with he
doesn't yeah this is idiotic but this
became a thing yesterday when a bunch of
celebrities started tweeting out that
they were cancelling their soul cycle
and equinox memberships not because soul
cycle and Equinox support Trump but
because one of the lead investors in
soul cycle and Equinox supports Trump
well if we're gonna do this routine then
we're gonna have to do corporates name
checks on every single major corporation
in the United States determined there
are no Trump supporters on the board
before the left is allowed to shop there
and I can't imagine anything that's
better for the country than having a gym
just for the left and a gym for the
right and having coffee shops just for
the left and coffee shops just for the
right the political segregation of our
society is not a good thing common space
where we actually see each other and
hang out with each other where we
tolerate the fact that they're opposing
political views if we can't do that it's
gonna be very difficult for us to live
in a republic together but this is what
the left one's well too many members
have left not ever again there's a
difference between the left and liberals
many liberals think this sort of stuff
is stupid but there are a lot of folks
on the Left who celebrate this because
they're standing up to that Hitler Trump
anybody who associates with Trump is
just a brown shirt hanging out with
Hitler and therefore we have to boy
would you fund Volkswagen in the middle
of the 1930s well Trump isn't Hitler
people who support Trump aren't Nazis if
you think they are then honestly you
should be the one picking up a gun
presumably because if Nazis are running
rampant across your country and are
actually in power shouldn't you do
something more than boycott SoulCycle
over it but apparently boycotting
SoulCycle is the way to virtues what
this is really about is virtue signaling
to your lefty friends your SJW friends
your woek friends that you're not gonna
stand up you're not gonna stand with
Trump right yeah I'm gonna burn my
Equinox shirt again 95% of the people
who go to Equinox in Los Angeles voted
for Democrats
ninety-five percent I'm sure and one of
the folks who works here I was talking
with her earlier she used to work at
Equinox and she happens to be an
immigrant of Mexican origin and she was
tweeting about this last night with some
folks and they immediately ascribed to
her white supremacist motivations which
is absurd and she used to work at
Equinox which he pointed out to people
is that when you boycott Equinox the
people who are the first to get hit are
not going to be people like Stephen Ross
he's gonna make his profit the people
who are the first to get hit are the
people who are the janitors or cleaning
up the gym afterward who
disproportionately are going to be of
more impoverished backgrounds and
probably disproportionately maybe of
immigrant backgrounds but people on the
Left don't care about any of this they
only care about the virtue signal and so
yeah Billy Eichner the actor he tweeted
out hey Equinox what's your policy for
canceling memberships once a member
finds out your own owner is enabling
racism and mass murder because Trump is
enabling racism and mass murder and thus
anybody who funds Trump is enabling
racism and mass murder that's the idea
from Billy Eichner okay then you have
Crissy Tyco at Teigen the wife of John
Legend and issue she is a singer correct
and Model Model Model thank you sorry
mice so my awareness of bubble-headed
Hollywood celebrities is a little bit
out of date Chrissy Teigen tweeted out
the gym is my personal hell but if
you're a member of Equinox perhaps it is
time to say peace out in ox a I'm still
sick yes but f equinox so all the
Hollywood celebs are coming out f
equinox we're gonna cancel our SoulCycle
memberships Michael Moore tweeted out
yesterday that he was gonna cancel his
membership at soul cycle which I mean
the good news is that frees up like
three seats it's soul cycle I mean it
this is this is all absurd it but not
only is it absurd it's actually very
dangerous for the country on a broader
level now there's a difference between
you cancel your subscription to The New
York Times because you don't like the
content of the New York Times or you
cancel your association with with an
organization because the organization's
policies are against your principles
there's a difference between that and an
investor in the organization holds
political principles you don't like I
shop at organizations all the time so do
you
they shop
advertisers all the time where I am sure
that there are members of the board and
chief investors in that board who
disagree with me politically that's good
for the country because commerce is
about the best product being available
to the most people for the cheapest
possible price it is not about me
pre-screening the politics of people who
will make money when I go to their store
so long as the store itself is not
pursuing evil policies like to take that
Volkswagen example from the 1930s
Volkswagen was working in concert with
the Hitler regime the Hitler designed
the VW Bug even if you think Donald
Trump is Hitler he didn't design the
SoulCycle guys but the goal here is of
course to segregate the population and
then to say that if you associate with
any member of the other side of the
political aisle that you are in effect
very very bad you must be canceled
that's the new language we got to cancel
everything so we're gonna boycott
everything we're gonna cancel everything
and then we declare ourselves morally
virtuous for having done so now is any
of this going to cut in favor of
Democrats come to once each one seat no
it's not this is the sort of stuff that
Trump is hoping for he likes these
culture wars if you haven't noticed this
is Trump's favorite sort of stuff like
if Trump really wants to troll today he
should say that he is joining SoulCycle
I mean we all know he's not gonna go
there and start bicycling right he has a
very interesting perspective on
exercised as our president he'll go I'm
gonna go there I'm gonna sit on the CEQA
just show super but my life energy I'm
not gonna deplete it by moving my legs
around like a crazy person
in any case turning our businesses into
battlegrounds over politics when the
business itself is not involved in
politics is a recipe for divisions in
the country and disintegration of the
social fabric it is indeed deeply deeply
stupid in nearly every possible way
sorry we'll get to more of that but
first I need to talk to you about
nutrition so I've been talking about
soul cycle and about fitness and through
this go to the gym get a membership get
more fit but if you really want to get
more fit if you really want to be more
healthy what you actually need is noon
okay noon is this fantastic app I
actually have been using it every single
day I started using it maybe three weeks
ago and my goal wants to lose maybe five
pounds and in about a month I've lost
about five pounds I know I'd really
didn't need to I was already jacked and
cut
let me just explain to you then Noom
really helps you get it done especially
if you find it hard to lose weight it
helps you develop specific goals that
you want to achieve and then gives you
all sorts of information that helps you
track calories have a great calorie
counter it helps you it has it part of
the app allows you to track your weight
so you can actually weigh yourself every
day and then it keeps track of all that
so you can see your trend it gives you
new information every day on your diet
tailored to you they have support groups
of people who are doing the same thing
that you are doing it really is
fantastic because what Noom is all about
is changing your habits right once you
start using the calorie counting app
then presumably you're going to be able
to count your calories more easily
becomes part of your habit and it really
becomes almost addictive which is good
being addicted to healthier living and
dieting is really really good for you
NUMA is based in psychology they teach
you why you do the things you do arms
with the tools to break the bad habits
and replace them with better ones
Newman's not a diet so healthy easy to
stick to way of life you don't have to
change it all in one day that's sort of
the theme small steps make big progress
sign up for your trout today at noon n
oom comm / Shapiro visit Noom comm / up
ero to start your trial today
that is Numa calm / up here it's the
last weight loss program you'll need and
I love it I've recommended it to my
parents as well it's an umma calm / up
here I'll go check it out alright so and
the Democrats have two choices as I said
at the outset choice number one go with
Chrissy Teigen and go with Billy Eichner
and start doing this everybody who's on
the other side is evil and bad and
horrible and wrong and racist and white
supremacists and likes shootings or you
could just critique Trump critiquing
Trump is actually a pretty rich vein as
it turns out Trump is not supremely
popular with the American people now
he's more popular than he was when he
was elected but he would need to see
another spike in his popularity to
really put him in safe reelect territory
right now he's about 42% 43% in the
public approval ratings if you were in
the 48 percent range she'd be a pretty
sure bet for reelect anywhere under 48
and it's at the very least a toss-up and
maybe favors the other side if you're if
you're not all Trump so the Democrats
have that choice and it seems like
pretty much every Democrat except for
Booker I mean except for a Joe Biden has
decided to go with the the crazies so ya
know so beta O'Rourke from El Paso he's
going around openly just saying that
Trump is a white supremacist again you
can critique from
for a lot of stuff Trump is not a white
supremacist if you think that Donald
Trump wants to establish white
nationhood and expel all the black and
brown people expel all that you're in I
mean is an insane contention Trump Trump
says dumb stuff dumb stuff that very
often borders on or crosses over into
casual racism that does not make him a
white supremacist he's not a white
supremacist this is absurd you believe
the president is a racist is the
president a white supremacist he is he's
also made that very clear he's
dehumanized or sought to do dehumanize
those who do not look like or pray like
the majority here in this country he
said I wish we had more immigrants from
Nordic countries because those from
Haiti bring aids those from Africa come
from whole nations he's been very clear
about who he prefers to be in this
country and who he literally wants to
keep out with walls and cages and
militarization and torture and cruelty
okay that is such an overplay nobody in
the united states by poll numbers there
there's a percentage but they're all
Democrats and most people the middle
don't believe that Trump is an actual
honest-to-god white supremacist and that
is not something that most people
actually believe the fact that that
folks like bata are pushing that that
that's an insane contention and then
bado goes even further and he says that
El Paso is gonna happen again if Trump
is elected so I guess that Trump is now
in control of all the white supremacist
and he's deploying them one by one to
Walmart's around the country and if
Trump is reelected then he's going to
really have a field day by unleashing
them on Hispanic people across the
country according to crazy bait oh are
you that with donald trump still in the
oval office something like this will
inevitably happen again it will happen
again because what happened in El Paso
is not an isolated incident after the
president warned of caravans you had
somebody go into the Tree of Life
synagogue in Pittsburgh warning of
caravans you had the mosque in Victoria
Texas burned to the ground on the day
that Trump signed his executive order
seeking to ban Muslim travel to the
United States so there are very real
consequences to his words to his tweets
to to the racism the fans just I'm sorry
this is ridiculous you can't predict
when evil people are going to do evil
stuff there's a white supremacist
during the administration of Barack
Obama walked into a Holocaust Memorial
in Washington DC and tried to shoot it
up hey there were riots in Ferguson in
Baltimore if bado can predict events
with this sort of accuracy dude should
get it on the stock market and really
blow up that fortune of his that he
inherited because this is this is the
sort of nonsense if you elect us then
we'll stop shootings but the other side
is not of it does this making the
rhetoric better is this making the
country better again we should I've been
saying all week long I was in for years
we should all be able to unify on the
notion that white supremacism is evil
and that mass shootings are evil but
there are many Democrats like meadow who
don't want to do that for political
purposes Cory Booker did this in a
softer way yesterday as well and he drew
his binary between agree with me and be
a white supremacist supporters who's
speaking at a historically I believe is
historically black church in Charleston
South Carolina in any case here well
here is Booker trying to draw a binary
between everybody who agrees with Cory
Booker and white supremacist real
question isn't who is or isn't a racist
but who is and isn't doing something
about it
this is a question that has a deep moral
resonance it's not enough to say I'm not
a racist we must be anti racism because
there's no neutrality in this fight you
are either an agent of justice or you
are contributing to the problem okay one
of the problems what cory booker is
saying here is that he never defines his
terms so I agree you either it can be
anti racism like overtly anti racism or
you can be Pro racism but there's not
really a neutral ground you can't just
be like I'm kind of having length on
racism like he can't do that obviously
but when he says do something what
exactly does that mean
because what are people quote-unquote
doing about it does that mean if you
don't cancel your SoulCycle membership
today then you are overtly advocating
for racism or is what he really means if
you don't back Democrats then you are a
racist
if you don't back Cory Booker you're
racist if you don't if you don't rip on
Trump daily and declare that you won't
vote for him and donate to his opponents
then you are a racist that is the false
binary that that the left is attempting
to draw and they're attempting to do so
in a clever way there are some things to
do so by refusing to define terms so I
have not said anything racist I've not
done anything racist because I'm not a
racist in fact I hate racism and I hate
white supremacists so much that they
hate me right back which is why we spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
here at this company to defend us from
death threats from white racists from
white supremacist hey but I would be
according to people like Booker and
people like presumably aoc a white
supremacist because I have expressed
support for many of Donald Trump's
policies and because I don't think the
Trump is a white supremacist so what the
left likes to do is throw out terms like
white supremacist without actually
defining them just like they wouldn't
define all right back in 2015 2016 the
alt-right was a threat in 2015 and 2016
they happen to be disgusting today but
there's an actual definition as to what
alt right means is the ideology of folks
like Richard Spencer it's the ideology
of folks like Vox Dei people who have
suggested that there is innate
biological difference between the races
such that some races are inferior and
some races are superior right that is
the that is the nature of white
supremacy that is a definition that I
just gave you but what the Left refuses
very often to do is provide definitions
of any of this stuff because they don't
want definitions
what they want is a broad miasmatic
sense like a miasma they wanted broad
sense of what white supremacy is without
having to define it so they can label
you a white supremacist if you disagree
with them on anything that is the goal
specificity in terms is really helpful
when you're having political
conversations or moral conversations
because then we can get to what we agree
on and what we disagree on so for
example I do not think that it is white
supremacy to oppose affirmative action
in fact I think it is racist to be in
favor of a any program that benefits one
race at the expense of another race and
is designed to do so but according to
members of the left it would be quote
unquote white supremacy presumably to
oppose affirmative action if you support
Trump in 2020 because you like his
policies and you don't think the Trump
is a racist you just think that he is a
a muddle-headed dolt who says doltish
things and clownish things on a regular
basis in the racial realm right if
you're one of those people the left will
declare you a white supremacist even if
you speak out forcefully every time you
think Trump crosses the line so the
point here is that for the left the
construction of a debate between white
supremacy and everything else is all
about obfuscating the line between white
supremacy and everything else we don't
know where the line is then I can put
you on the other side of the line
anytime I want it's a perfect example of
that yesterday so Alexander Ocasio
Cortez puts out this long tweed thread
about white supremacy and she is
deliberately defining white supremacy
down and she's deliberately defining it
down to finding things down is a phrase
once used by daniel patrick moynihan
with regard to deviancy what he
suggested is that as a society what
we're constantly doing in order to
excuse our own sin is we define sin down
meaning things that used to be
considered sinful and deviant are no
longer sinful and deviant he used the
example of single motherhood
he said that when you define single
motherhood as quote unquote the new
normal it's no longer deviant it's now
normalized and you get more of it well
the left is defining white supremacy
down in a different way what they're
doing is they're saying everything is
white supremacy so what do you get well
you actually end up getting more of is
people labeling each other white
supremacist and that's what the left
ones okay so now to a o'seas thread so
alc tweets this out yesterday quote
there is a difference between white
supremacists and white supremacy okay
first of all when she says this what
she's actually attempting to do now is
take the definition of white supremacy
and broaden it out to include a bunch of
people who are not members of the
alt-right who don't write manifestos
about Hitler who don't go and shoot up
I'll pass or Walmart who are who are out
there right they they suffer from white
supremacy as you'll see wait until she
broadens this definition because it's so
broad that it encompasses it can
encompass it can be shaped to encompass
nearly anything so she says there's a
difference between white supremacists
and white supremacy so first move in
this in this broadening of the
definition you can't say you're not a
white supremacist just because you're
not a white supremacist maybe you are
maybe you suffer from white supremacy
and you just don't know it she says
white supremacy is like a virus they
still know definition but it's like a
virus meaning that it infects people it
jumps from person to person without them
knowing it because you don't know if
you're sick
she says supremacists are those who have
been completely overcome by the disease
but supremacy the virus exists on a
larger scale beyond just the infected it
also lays dormant so just to be clear
the virus I go back to the prior tree
forcing the virus says the virus exists
on a larger scale beyond white
supremacists and also can lie dormant so
you can never have exhibited any symptom
of white supremacy but still you can
suffer from white supremacy you can be a
carrier of white supremacy so now you
don't have to be an overt racist a
covert racist a person who knows they're
racist a person who has ever evidenced
any symptom of white supremacy and still
you can be an agent of white supremacy
because it's lying dormant in you here's
a look how this is blown up from small
group of white supremacists and all
writers who are dangerous to anyone at
any time
who could suffer from this thing that's
a virus called white supremacy again
white supremacy exists it has a specific
definition it is deeply evil I'm
fighting these people on a daily basis I
know it they've threatened my family but
a OC is deliberately attempting to make
this movement it's a dangerous move for
the country so a OC continues with this
thread and she suggests white supremacy
is often subconscious so it's not even
conscious you don't even know if you're
a white supremacist or if you suffer
from white supremacy so you can you can
yet you can demonstrate no symptoms you
don't have to know you're a member of
the white supremacist class it's a
conscious and its dormant but you can
still suffer from it says clearly our
nation has not been inoculated white
supremacy is our nation's original sin
the driving logic of slavery of native
genocide of Jim Crow of segregation of
mass incarceration of send her back
hey now she's conflating a lot of stuff
okay so yes white supremacy is the
driving logic of slavery and of Native
genocide and again the question of
native genocide is slightly more
complicated the mistreatment of Native
Americans in the United States is
horrific and well known to call it a
full-on genocide I think is an
overstatement because usually people are
talking about lots of Native Americans
dying of disease ethnic cleansing you
know as far as forcibly moving Native
Americans out of areas that were legally
entitled to and into reservations I
think would be a probably be a more
accurate term which is of Jim Crow fair
of segregation fair and mentions of mass
incarceration and this is where she
brings slavery all the way up to date
and she says that if you are in favor of
harsh policing of crime and lots of
people who commit crime go to jail and
they are disproportionately of color
then you are a white supremacist right
she's and she's deaf again broadening
out that definition she's still not
defined white supremacy we're were two
to what three tweets in here two tweets
in and she's still not to find the term
she's talking about she's just giving
you symptoms of the term she says it
never went away
it was just dormant okay so it was it
was dormant it never went away so again
bunch of people who didn't side with any
of the stuff that she likes that she's
talking about here those people could
have been carriers and then she
continues again this is broadening and
broadening until it means nothing
healing ourselves of white supremacy
will be hard normally when you diagnose
someone with a disease you have to
define the disease what does the disease
do how is it treated what exactly can
you expect its development course to be
if you're a doctor and you just say you
know what you suffer from cancer and
somebody says what is cancer and the
doctor goes I don't know it was dormant
for a while now it's here it's bad not
helpful and if you say that you can't
tell what is cancer and what isn't
cancer then you're a horrible doctor so
she's a horrible doctor she says healing
ourselves with white supremacy will be
hard it will be hard because it requires
us to confront ourselves we wish it was
as simple as denouncing a white hood a
burnt cross vile language but we need to
address where supremacy begin
not just where it ends yeah this is the
sort of language that the left loves
because she's never defining where it
begins and she's saying that if you
stand up and you say the KKK is evil and
you say that vile language is bad and
you say that some of the president's
comments crossed the line and when you
if you stand up to if you say white
supremacist our garbage if you say all
that stuff that still doesn't mean
you're not a white supremacist because
you haven't address for white supremacy
began now does she define where White's
you promised you begins again she keeps
begging the question where does this
begin what is the definition this would
be important again if you're going to
diagnose the transmission of a virus and
you're going to explain how to prevent
the virus shouldn't you do that at some
point she continues we need to address
where supremacy begins says perhaps she
says perhaps more than the obvious last
steps of the supremacist we must examine
the nuance of their first steps again
she's not actually explaining what the
first steps are she's not explaining
what the first steps are because what
she wants to say is that being the first
step means being conservative a
Republican that's what she wants out of
this in the end the place that she
doesn't actually say out loud but where
she wants to go is that if you are
against affirmative action if you
believe in if you're against criminal
criminal justice reform for example if
you believe that police forces across
the nation are not systemic ly racist if
you believe that America's legal
institutions are not institutionally
racist that the legacy of racism and
slavery obviously has after-effects
because history always has after-effects
into the present but that America is
under its current legal regime the
fairest nation in the history of the
world with regard to race that if you
believe all of that those are the first
steps right because she never labels
what the first steps are she says what
the last steps are which means that you
could right now without knowing it be on
the slippery slope to white supremacy
you could it could be dormant in you
it could be subconscious you might not
even recognize what you think about
things and you could be on that slippery
slope all the way down into white
supremacy no Tucker Carlson is getting a
lot of flack for saying that white
supremacism isn't a problem in the
United States I'm my radio show
yesterday I criticized him for it I
think that he's absolutely wrong white
supremacism is of course a problem in
the United States and Tucker was trying
to make the statistical case that there
aren't that many white supremacists in
the United States and that is
statistically
true but their statistical speaking
weren't that many Isis members in the
United States that was a problem
white supremacism is in fact a problem
but what a OC is doing here by
suggesting that white supremacy is
everywhere is just as much of a problem
because instead of underplaying it she's
now suggesting that what 60 70 80 300
million Americans are secret white
supremacist and don't even know it she
says recognizing white supremacy in
ourselves our institution our
subconscious our own past remarks or
acts no matter how consciously
unintentional I don't know what
consciously unintentional means is what
makes the healing work ahead challenging
but it is not impossible and confronting
it is the only way to move forward again
what she is doing is now setting herself
up as the arbiter of what white
supremacy is without defining it which
is the mark of arbitrary judgment it is
the mark of a bad politician and frankly
the mark of a bad person morally if a
person says I have a moral standard I'm
not gonna tell you what it is but I'll
tell you when you violated it that that
person should not be your moral standard
obviously because they are not
trustworthy and this is what is
undermining trust in the moral standard
it's why the right looks at the left and
says okay you guys are ripping on racism
all the time we're fine with that but um
how about that al Sharpton guide that
you were praising like a week ago
well yeah you were you were talking
about bigotry and how bigotry is bad and
AOC is taking magazine covers with Villa
Hannah Omar and sponsoring legislation
with her no you don't get to be the
arbiter because your standard is not
only unclear it is cynically defined in
order to put people who you don't like
outside the box and keep yourself in a
OC concludes with this this clever and
yet dangerous tweet thread says what
this moment is asking of us is to
discuss white supremacy and racism as
much or possibly more than white
supremacists and racists when we do that
I believe we'll start to make progress
well actually if we do it in the way
that she's talking about it will be the
opposite of progress because this is
just excuse making for her calling
everybody she doesn't like a racist and
this isn't that that's all this is when
you boil all this down what this means
is that she's given no definition of
white supremacy she's given no
definition of those first steps toward
white supremacy she's just gonna sit
there and on a case-by-case basis tell
you that you're the problem because I
don't see her doing it's so funny she
talks here about ourselves
self-examination
was the last time you heard a OC talk
about pearl and self-examination of her
own inherent bigotry ever of course not
she means you says it it's incredibly
important we recognize that perfectly
normal good people are capable of aiding
racism and white supremacy so you're a
good person and you're normal but you're
still aiding racism and white supremacy
this brings you full so a first full
circle to the soul cycle equinox
nonsense she's recognizing that it is
not about pillar iing people yeah I'm
sure it's about learning to recognize
the virus and end an oppressive system
designed to hurt us all yeah if sure
lady I'm sure that this is not about
pillow nearing people I'm sure that you
will never act in bad faith and simply
call your political opponents like Nancy
Pelosi racists just because it serves
your political ends I'm sure that you
will engage in deep self-reflection
today about your own bigotry and helping
out el Han Omar I'm sure this this kind
of trash and this is what's going to
again condemning white supremacy is
fully not only in bounds praiseworthy
but you got to define the term and the
left is deliberately undefined the term
so they can then apply it to everybody
on a broad scale and that is it's so
wrong
it is incredibly wrong it is labeling
tens of millions of Americans who oppose
white supremacy white supremacist but of
course that is the political goal for
the radical left now speaking of
radicalism we're gonna get to CNN's
townhall on gun control in just a second
but first you have to go over to daily
wire comm and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription for $99
a year you can get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels the annual
subscription comes along with the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler as I
always point out leftists years now
liberal tears lots of good liberals
leftist years which we are happy
together because they are censorious and
nasty by the way we saw yesterday the
Media Matters had put together a
seven-month compilation of some of the
other hosts here at Daily wire and
they'd been watching the shows and so my
question was I hope they enjoyed their
left is tears tumblr because presumably
in order to watch all of the shows in
their completion they actually had to
subscribe so I hope they're enjoying
that they they cry into the tears drink
them and then use them as fuel to power
themselves to watch more of our shows so
well done over there at Media Matters
what horrible people there already if
you want to watch listen you wanna be
part of the mailbag tomorrow you should
subscribe
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so speaking of radicalism last night CNN
does another one of these CNN town halls
and the NRA didn't participate because
why would they last time there was a CNN
Town Hall on guns
it was the Parkland town hall Dana lash
was brought forth so that people could
shower her in Rotten Tomatoes and Marco
Rubio is brought forth so that members
of the audience could suggest that he
had committed a mass shooting well Chris
Cuomo the stupider of the Cuomo brothers
he decided that he was he was gonna host
this thing and Chris Cuomo knows less
than nothing about guns
he really knows nothing normally when
you have somebody moderate a Town Hall
on a topic they should know a thing
about the thing they are talking about
but that is not a prerequisite of having
a job at CNN how do I know this because
Chris Cuomo tweeted out this morning
about the Second Amendment and he's been
tweeting this kind of stuff incessantly
it's just ridiculous 24 Chris Cuomo
tweeted out do you remember what the
Second Amendment was created for that
there was no individual right
contemplated until Scalia read it in if
you are an originalist about the
Constitution you have no basis for
thinking you and not the state controls
access to guns this is patently insane
it's ignorant it's ridiculous it would
be almost funny except for the fact that
Chris Cuomo was hosting a town hall on
this particular topic yesterday does he
really think that Justice Antonin Scalia
in 2008 in the Heller vs. DC case
established an individual right to keep
and bear arms is that what he thinks
what has it been for the last couple of
hundred years dolt
the actual wording of the Second
Amendment a well-regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
State the right of the people to keep
and bear Arms shall not be infringed hey
that last part is what we call the
operative clause all the rest is
preparatory okay the right of the people
not the right of the state not the right
of the militia the right of the people
to keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed the people were the militia I
mean you have to be so historically
ignorant to believe what he's saying in
that tweet a militia was comprised of
people who got together and then formed
the militia they kept the guns at their
houses you didn't have to be a member of
the militia in order to own a gun but
because a militia was important you
needed to have people who own guns so
from that population you could call a
militia the Second Amendment was written
specifically at the behest of the
anti-federalists who opposed the
Constitution and who are guaranteed they
were pushing for a guarantee at the
federal government
would not regulate the ownership of guns
anyone who spent five minutes studying
this topic knows that except for John
Paul Stevens who wished to wish to reach
a different conclusion because he was
driven by his outcome which was that he
wanted gun regulation anyway Chris Cuomo
hosts this dumb CNN Town Hall the NRA
doesn't show up and then Chris Cuomo
rips them for not showing up so if you
don't show up to his party where he's
going to poop on your head then you're
very bad and stupid person according to
Chris Cuomo we also invited the National
Rifle Association the NRA to be part of
tonight's conversation they declined
they sent a totally disingenuous
statement that they're open to honest
discussion but not this spectacle that's
what you call this a spectacle I guess
they want to do their talking with
propaganda ads and millions in lobbying
okay besides yes yes yes yes you you yes
you you fool yes this is a spectacle of
course it's a spectacle what have you
ever done on gun control are you a
legislator were you elected of course
it's a spectacle we all know it's a
spectacle the NRA has got some internal
problems right now they aren't wrong
about this this obviously is true this
is a spectacle he said like I love that
he goes it wouldn't show up calling this
a spectacle well that's fine because
they're just a bunch of paid lobbyists
anyway and they're they're starting to
obstruct the issue okay so you just you
you you just proved their point their
whole point is that you were gonna be a
politically driven actor and you were
going to go after anyone who is pro
Second Amendment and then when you read
their statement you proceeded to do just
that I can't imagine why the NRA didn't
show up to hear the dumber Cuomo brother
the Fredo of the of the Cuomo family
exploited he's very smart
he's smart explain why it why it is that
the NR I didn't show up unreal unreal
okay so as I say it's it's this sort of
crazy
polarizing extremism the attacks on
people who like the Second Amendment the
deliberate the deliberate obfuscation of
the issues all this kind of stuff that
leads from to get elected in 2016 so
Trump has to hope that that's what
Democrats do in 2020 or alternatively he
could change his behavior well this is
the part where I say Trump is not going
to change his behavior because Trump
isn't going to change his behavior so he
visited Dayton and El Paso yesterday and
that was fine and he kept it pretty much
on the down
which is how it should be okay this is
not a photo-op then he proceeded to
release a bunch of photos of himself in
Dayton and in El Paso when he could have
just quietly done it I remember George W
Bush quietly going to Iraq for example
George W Bush used to quietly go to
Walter Reed it was very nice
Obama never used to do this and I used
to criticize Obama for it then dance
Covino the press they comms leader over
at the White House he'd tweeted out
President Trump with the incredible
medical staff at Miami Valley Hospital
in Dayton Ohio today some extremely
powerful moments throughout the entire
visit with so much enthusiasm and love
contrary to what the Trump hating Dems
whatever share or say and then he
followed that one up by calling the
president a rock star he said the
President Trump is a rock star for going
here and was treated like a rock star
hey is that really your pitch like you
went to a place where people just got
shot in mass shooting and they all loved
seeing their great president because
he's like a rock star I'm sorry the
appeals to Trump's ego are not going to
help him they're not going to help him
win reelection it's also not gonna help
him win reelection when the president
heading out to El Paso and Dayton
decides to tweet out about how bado has
a phony name and bado is the worst and
tweets had about sherrod Brown talks
about how his hospital visit was totally
misrepresented it underscores a feeling
that a lot of Americans have which is
that the president is actually a petty
man and that the president lacks moral
fiber this is why I say that if the
Democrats could just act sane they'd be
in pretty good shape for 2020 if however
they decide that they are the party of
boycotting Equinox and leaving CNN Town
Hall's where they rip into gun rights
and that everybody who opposes them as
white supremacists then Trump will win
reelection now Joe Biden gave a speech
yesterday trade Joe Biden is seen by
most Democrats is the most electable
Democrat the reason is because of the
speech he gave yesterday now the speech
deliberately misrepresented a lot of the
comments that Trump has made on a
variety of topics so for example Biden
said in his speech yesterday that Trump
hadn't condemned the KKK now back in
2016 Trump did appear on CNN and
pretended he didn't know what the KKK
was he then condemned the KKK as it
turns out he's condemning the KKK many
many times and here's a full-on
compilation of President Trump
condemning the KKK because Trump has
done it
a lot as it turns out he doesn't deny
them at a minimum so I totally disavow
the Ku Klux Klan I totally disavow David
Duke when you say the party is
self-destructing what do you see as the
biggest problem with the reform party
right now well you've got David Duke
just joined a bigot a racist a problem I
mean this is not exactly the people you
want in your party are you prepared
right now to make a clear and
unequivocal statement renouncing the
support of all white supremacists of
course I am of course ok so again he has
done this over and over and over and
over and over again so that's just not
true in any case Biden is launching an
attack on Trump's character and that is
sort of it sort of it's the same
campaign that George W Bush ran against
Bill Clinton in mm and mm George W Bush
was running on the back of a policy
successful presidency with a president
who was deeply unpopular on the basis of
character so he's popular overall but on
character questions people thought that
Clinton was a bleep show because he was
a bleep show I took W ran against that
he said he's gonna bring honor back to
the oval office it was such a damaging
attack that Al Gore had to forcibly move
himself away from Bill Clinton he
refused to campaign even with Bill
Clinton then he proceeds to lose a very
narrow election he wins the popular vote
but loses the electoral college right so
now Joe Biden is trying to run mm in
Reverse he's trying to say that sure
president Trump maybe there are some
good policies although whole-number a
minute maybe there are some good
policies but his character is the real
problem and Joe Biden has some things to
mind here right I mean the fact is the
President does have a lot of character
shortcomings the president cannot
control himself on Twitter the president
says bad things on a fairly regular
basis and so while it is true that Joe
Biden is deliberately misconstruing a
lot of the stuff that Trump has said and
doing so in dishonest fashion it is also
true that politically speaking what he's
doing here is a lot smarter than the
other Democrats the other Democrats are
suggesting that Joe Biden was a racist
for signing on to the criminal justice
bill in 1994 and the mass incarceration
is inherently racist and all this kind
of stuff ripping on Barack Obama
suggesting that everybody who disagrees
with them is white supremacists and
Biden is focusing in just on Trump right
regardless of whether you think that
he's
about Trump and I think some of what he
says here is a lie about Trump
regardless of whether you think that
they pitch that he is making is the
strongest political pitch says clip
eight talking about how this is a battle
for the soul of our nation
this is him making the George W Bush
circa 2000 appeal about how we need to
restore some sense of honor and dignity
to the like the fact that Joe Biden is
the person the Democrats have chosen for
this is fairly insane I mean Uncle Joe
has a lot in his closet Uncle Joe says
some dumb nonsense he said some pretty
borderline stuff himself but it is the
strongest pitch the Democrats are making
what he said after Charlottesville there
were and I quote very fine people on
both sides I said at the time we're in a
battle for the soul of this nation I
said it again when I announced my
candidacy and I say it here today we are
in a battle for the soul of this nation
hey but what Biden didn't do right okay
so what Biden didn't do there and this
is the part about what he's doing smart
is he didn't trip everybody on the right
side of the aisle as complicit in what
he termed to be Trump's attacks on the
soul of the nation right that and that's
where he's gonna have to stay because if
he moves into cory booker territory
where you're either voting for Joe Biden
or you're evil people will say go take a
hike nobody's interested if he moves
into the aoc realm of I'm everybody's
vaguely defined white supremacist except
for me then he's gonna be in serious
trouble and this is why Joe Biden I
think Democrats innately understand this
unfortunately for Trump and for
Republicans I think Democrats understand
that he is the most electable Democrat
this is why the new Iowa Democratic
caucus polled shows 28% for Joe Biden
19% for Elizabeth Warren 11% for Camille
Harris 9% for Bernie Sanders so again is
he being honest about everything the
trumpet said no he's not being honest
about everything that the Trump has said
the very fine people on both sides
comment was specifically referring to
the Friday night rally Trump explicitly
said in that same speech that he
condemned neo-nazism
and that he condemned white supremacist
and then he made up in his head some
weird group of people who were marching
with the marchers who for some reason
were good people but they were they
at the unite the right rally which was
absurd and gross and ridiculous and
morally reprehensible but carrying that
to the extent that Trump was the same
white supremacist are good people is of
course not true right of course that is
not correct with that said the character
attacked that Biden is making on Trump
is the attack that is most likely to
work on Trump which is why he's the most
successful Democrat at the moment and
why if Democrats continue to move down
the radical path Trump will be reelected
if they nominate Joe Biden much better
shot that Joe Biden ends up president
than any of the other Democrats who are
on that stage right now okay time for
some things I like and then perhaps we
will do anything I hate so things that I
like today there's a new poll it shows
that half of young people say that
college is not necessary that it's too
expensive and no longer necessary so
which I say good it's about time it's
about time there's an article from
MarketWatch
they say that there's a study surveyed
over 3,000 US teens and adults including
approximately 1,000 generation z1000
young Millennials and 1,000 parents
about one in five generations and young
Millennials say they may choose not to
go to college many others see a less
conventional path through education as a
good idea over 30 percent of Generation
Z and 18 percent of young Millennials
said they've considered taking a gap
year between high school and college
what's more 89 percent of Generation Z
along with nearly 79 percent of young
Millennials have considered an education
path that looks different from a
four-year degree directly out of high
school well I certainly hope that's the
case because there is no greater scam in
America today
then a liberal arts education at
$100,000 a year college that is a
massive scam it is one thing to go to
college as I said before in order to
learn a skill set but if you're going to
college just that you can be
indoctrinated in gender studies and
you're gonna pay couple hundred thousand
dollars for the privilege you're making
a big mistake and get those same online
courses at an extension school for 50
bucks of credit and you'll learn just as
little so this is this is really it's a
good thing I think young people are
beginning to see the scam for what it is
hopefully employers start to see the
scam for what it is here at the Daily
wire we actually do not look at
educational background when assessing
whether or not somebody should be hired
that's because my business partner
Jeremy boring didn't go to college he
went like a music school for a year and
a half and then dropped out and so
when people have brought him job
descriptions to be put in the
classifieds he is taken out like
literally crossed out the educational
requirements because he says listen I'm
the CEO of the company and I didn't go
to college so how can I require anybody
who wants to work here to go to college
how about they show a skill set and then
they can work here this seems to be much
more reasonable I think most employers
should imitate that ok time for a quick
thing that I hate so president from for
some god-awful reason says he is now
gonna consider commutation for rod
Blagojevich I have no idea why this
makes no sense at all I understand you
may remember Rob Blagojevich from when
they were on the apprentice together
because everything is so stupid but why
in the world would you commute the
sentence of rod Blagojevich one of the
more corrupt Illinois politicians in the
recent past he's currently serving a
14-year prison term on multiple federal
corruption convictions Trump suggested
more than a year ago he was considering
a commutation for little blue guy ovitch
who then filed paperwork requesting a
commutation and then Wednesday night he
told the press corps that he thought
Blagojevich had been treated to quote
unbelievably unfairly he said that he
was taking in consideration Blagojevich
his wife and children and what was in
his view mirror braggadocio Liguria vich
of course has been in prison since 2012
why why is there a purpose to this is
Blagojevich actually innocent I haven't
seen a lot of accusations to that to
that effect this sort of bizarre
behavior again Trump does not have to
make a headline every day it's a source
of consistency irritation to the general
public
it's a source of consistent irritation
to many members of his own staff the
bizarre notion that Trump has to make a
headline every day to drive the news
cycle why don't you just let the Dems be
in the news cycle for a day you know
calling everybody white supremacist and
boycotting Equinox how about that how
about Rob Blagojevich I mean the clip by
the way the clips of Trump chiding Rob
Blagojevich on The Apprentice about not
doing his proper research on Harry
Potter are pretty golden they do exist
there they're really they're really
quite amazing and I'm glad that our
country is now being run in such a way
that if you were once in a contestant on
The Apprentice or if you cut a really
hot R&B
or if you are a rapper who is fond of
Kim Kardashian that we will work our
asses off to make sure that you get out
of prison in Sweden very very important
stuff really important stuff all right
we'll be back here later today for two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show left-wing hate
site Media Matters launches an attack on
the daily wire will crush them see them
driven before us and hear the
lamentations of their women on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin